[Music]
and rainforests save your news submitted
by I am PewDiePie seriously really you
watch your channel cool any work on
something puny that ain't you
[ __ ] but if it is say hi l if
it is can I get some money an 83 year
old man spent the last four decades
successfully bringing a forest back to
life
whoa 84 83 how much water is this phone
wasted so for 40 years he's been
watering plants and forests
he just left the hose on the whole time
can I say this to all those other people
out there talking about come on please
please save the rainforests you ain't
[ __ ] [ __ ] this dude actually did it
your [ __ ] Twitter warriors punk ass
[ __ ] I never let anyone treat about
the rain horse they talking about saving
the rainforest climate change all the
time but they still the ones taking 40
minute showers
[ __ ] I'm rehabilitating the
plants in our office yeah I see them
coming back to life real quick though uh
macaque dish got off to my bird never
cactus outsider he had like circular I'd
like this mini baby cactus his name is
three finger Steve right why are you it
like Steve oh now the other one is Frank
Hamer yeah it's three fingers Steve
right three three fingers people it look
like you're doing this right and then I
saw a bird come up and it sucked up my
cactus and hit one is our song
oh no that's no finger yeah now no now
steed you look like a dick because it is
like once I get out [ __ ] it pissed me
off man was it one of those cacti that
has one of these could every every once
a month I leave an outside for about a
week and then it gets its sunlight yeah
so now this is this - uh-huh yeah I just
protect it they just like won't and then
just [ __ ] mouth one off I think it
didn't realize how spiky it was stupid
fire yes an 83 year old man
I'm Sonya recently from she's from
Brazil so he's saying 40 years ago back
in 1973 he bought this land which was
about 76 acres Wow
so this land it had already been raised
for cattle grazing so there was no trees
nothing
all he decimated it yeah and so he took
a challenge to try to bring back to the
rainforest compute said like he
remembers and he was a child he would be
like living like near where he lived
like there was always this rainforest
and he could experience that but then he
saw that this country the government
they wanted to boost up agriculture
industry and so they were just tearing
down all of the rainforest so it really
made him sad and he's thinking like well
what about the kids of the future
they're not going to be able to see like
when I grew up with so for the past 40
years you've been nurturing this entire
environment I'm going to show you guys a
video it may be a born after very long
this is on Sonya oh he doesn't this
reinforces his family let's go can I
can't give the best hugs more salacious
mahogany might break apart kedaranatha
key home attendant eco-friendly I came
from a school I started to form over
ship in a normal intelligence
Indian Patricia jessica zufolo
illusion Joey acaba with a 23-window
compare your kids they love to do parks
yes Minotaur pasta kappa y nunca mais
delta ofq 50 sighs oh god whimpers oh
God
traveling moon Tupac on playa Sofia
yo estoy a party knows Venus on Venus Oh
educating Rita you a fatality para todo
el estado Kumar Sanus pupa the you want
to cash available before I go to
Coachella
though I could be a funny guy a sucky
Wow about 26 acres 76 Ocean [ __ ]
man that guy is freaking Derek I wonder
if he bought like few acres and kept
building on it because you said he went
to the city so he could buy the land
yeah he worked hard because that's a lot
of freaking money you think here was a
gigolo how did he make all that money no
so he actually arrived way enough news
credit to buy the land that the
government was handing out to promote
deforestation and in order to increase
like agriculture technology so he can
use credit that the government was
giving out along with the fact that he
was working really hard to be a part of
that land that makes more sense than to
hang that tie replanted a whole forest
yeah it's so crazy
that's so cool there's there's actually
a lot of people like this there's
someone and I think Pakistan or India
and there's an island there that's like
deserted but then it was it was like
Island in between rivers or lakes or
something like that but it's eroding but
then this guy is saving it by creating
like this huge Oasis forest and you've
been doing it for like the past decade
or something like that I got asked are
planning should do the plants are so
hard to take care of god man I was Green
Zone yeah yeah I buy a plant I have a
[ __ ] black thumb dude just BAM
I see the smart the smart gardening I
just get them all plastic Oh see that's
like I do I know so I know the fate of
the plants if I purchase it it's dead so
I rather let someone that knows what
they're doing
save it you control all the plans in my
office are all fake the [ __ ] cuz
of my cat stuff that potted one of my
succulents contacted the soil too hard
so the plant was dying a little down
site so I had to do my own research I
was like Gil I'm watering it correctly I
know what I'm doing right I need a plant
food and then I was like the soil was so
tense it wouldn't even break up and then
I reading I reading I reading that if
there's to come compacted like
suffocates the plant broke that [ __ ] up
and I was coming back to life
okay go you do have a green thumb though
don't because the other ones are Steve
Ibaka that wasn't oh I should have known
I should do it if I see that bird on the
[ __ ] them up
that could be all look so different no I
put out a little string thing with what
the budget seeds on it I'm a [ __ ]
novice with the finish up super [ __ ]
choke them in the neck another [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's what value was good cutter
yeah you [ __ ] three fingers Steve I'm
gonna make him sit on three fingers
Steve my Birds help plants too because
their [ __ ] has like seeds when they eat
something and then they plant yeah
laughter I [ __ ] them up I'm gonna put
some [ __ ] seed in his mouth and send
those way every fragrance Antonio
planted over fifty thousand tree goddamn
dedication yeah it was like every single
tree here I planted with my own hands
that's my dream inside when you first
started doing this his neighbors were
cattle and dairy farmers they always
would tell him like you're so dumb
planting trees is a waste of land you
won't have any income it's full of trees
you won't have room for cows or crops
he's like I don't care I'm bringing the
rainforest back so how is he good how is
he keeping or making money or doing all
that stuff I was curious about that too
but I didn't dig alone CD Brazilian
gigolo if you're smart to start like a
little touring oh yeah
welcome to my eye forty years later who
got the last laugh [ __ ] your land
smells like Dookie but mine is so cool I
hope he knows that he has a transfer
this land of somebody I said I'll take
care of it when he passes away I know I
was thinking that he ain't got no kids
I'm gonna don't give it back to the
government they're gonna cut it down no
water rights all the water out there is
dried up right so he can pretty much say
Oh agent joke count bursting [ __ ] haha
he's saying that twenty new water
sources surface in his land and now
there's a eight waterfalls you know who
else did this in America state I think
he was a former founder of churches or
Popeyes Chicken the franchise and then
after he sold the company and he was
super ballin he his project was to find
the most
excellent garbage land in the west side
of Texas and then terraform that
[ __ ]
so he decided to stop planting and
changing some [ __ ] up and it was all
dried up
and what they found out was there was
all these reserved type of caves that
used to hold water but doesn't know more
but it attracted moisture they started
filling up and then like after a couple
of decades later it's a lush area and
now they hold classes there of you want
to be able to terraform come here we'll
teach you do you want to do that right
yeah I just want to find chicken fried
chicken with a few of the resources all
mountain churches gun you live in my
dream actually Fried Chicken franchise
and then building some [ __ ] yeah but
it's so sweet does he thing I didn't do
it for money I did it because when I die
what's here will remain for everyone
people don't call me crazy anymore yeah
they had didn't see anything of course
so it's like I'm going to go away and
forest looks alright dumbass and then
now in your face I'm 80 50 years old and
what you got this behind you did see was
a for thinker yeah you was cookie said
like he could see that the water sources
is drying up and he saw this is the
long-term effects of it he's like I
don't care about making money I want to
make sure that I preserve nature here's
all the cattle and all the irrigation
for the plants was taking a bottled
water huh you think ever jacked off in
the forest well it's your mind all for
nothing that's not huge right it's like
76 acres so there's time to is planting
trees and he's positive like hella far
away from the house because he's like I
don't know like 20 acres in and then
he's camping out for the night and he
might be like I'm kind of horny right
now and there's no ladies
Milo jackoff in the forest who the
hell's going to know I'm assuming
probably at least like couple hundred
times in the forest at this age no no
wandering the forty three years of
planning I don't think so because my
dick always shrinks in the forest
what's not you sexy [ __ ] useless
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want to
follow us you could check out all our
[ __ ] link to the description box
below you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then that
videos are up there
[Applause]